mi prima nadie está tomando un curso de
cálculo para el verano y ayer me habló
por teléfono porque tenía unos problemas
de límites y pensé que eran excelentes y
que valía la pena hacerlos en un vídeo
así que de todos modos vamos lo que
vamos a hacer son esos límites y si no
mal recuerdo
espero llevar a cabo las respuestas como
lo hice ayer en el teléfono no me lo sé
de memoria pero bueno espero que sí si
lees te atinando a lo que platiqué ayer
con mi prima así que vamos a calcular el
límite cuando z tiende a 2 de 1 no no es
x se trata de una zeta vamos a deshacer
deshacer ok de del cuadrado de zeta
+ 2 zeta
menos -8 y todo esto sobre z a la 4 - 16
muy bien así que lo primero que quiero
hacer cuando quiero calcular un límite
es evaluar en el límite y ver si tiene
una respuesta correcta pero no tenemos
qué
cuando nos aproximamos a 2 en el
denominador
tenemos un problema verdad porque 2 a la
4 es 16 y menos 16 es cero así que no
está definido
tenemos que buscar otra manera de
conseguir resolver el límite y realmente
nueve de cada diez veces que vean esta
expresión significa que tenemos que
factorizar las expresiones ok así que
bueno vamos a ver cómo factorizar lo
esto será el límite cuando se te atiende
a dos de quién es el numerador factor
izado digamos dos números que sumamos me
den dos y multiplicados menos ocho pues
simplemente pueden ser cuatro y menos
dos verdad entonces esto me queda x más
no que no es una equis y estoy tan
condicionado a esto soy como un perro
ya no puedo deshacer bueno vamos a
escribir la zeta
esto es zeta
z
no quiero ser incómodo déjenme déjenme
borrar esto vamos a deshacer esto hay
que suponer que no pasó nada aquí
entonces esto es z más cuatro por z
menos 2
y luego qué es lo que tenemos abajo en
el denominador tenemos una diferencia de
cuadrados verdad es de la forma cuadrada
menos b cuadrada donde a cuadrada pues
es se está cuadrada entonces vamos a
tener que colocar una seta cuadrada se
está cuadrada más 4 x se está cuadrada
menos 4 y luego por supuesto esta
segunda tiene una forma de diferencia de
cuadrados por lo que este factor será z
más 2 z más 2 por zeta menos 2 y ya
quedó porque este factor z - 2 es el que
nos estaba dando 0 en el denominador y
ahora podremos quitarlo verdad lo
podemos suponiendo que z no es 2 podemos
simplificar con el numerador así que
para todos los demás valores podemos
decir que se está menos 2 se va se va el
tanto el del número numerador como el
denominador y entonces que nos queda nos
queda el límite
cuando se te atiende a 2
de z4 sobre se está cuadrada más cuatro
por z más 2
correcto y ahora esto es igual a que
buenos z + 42 46 y luego 2 al cuadrado
más 4 es 8 por 2 más 2 que es 4 y nos
queda 6 sobre 4 por 8 32 y ahí lo tienen
pensé que era un problema bastante
interesante para límites vamos a hacer
otro y este me pareció todavía más
interesante ella me dio en realidad
déjenme ver si me acuerdo quizás no
obtenga el número exacto que me había
dado ella pero espero recapitular las
propiedades exactas que había que
utilizar así que va a ser el límite
cuando x tiende a infinito de la de la
expresión de raíz cuadrada de x al
cuadrado más 4 x más 1 y luego le
restamos x
y bueno así que cuando nos fijamos en
esto que es lo que está pasando aquí
miren a medida que x avance es el
infinito este término realmente se hace
grande entonces nos estamos tomando la
raíz cuadrada de eso y parece que este
término en realidad se va apareciendo a
equis verdad x cuadrada y le saco raíz
cuadrada y luego le restó x podríamos
pensar que se acerca a 0 y eso fue mi
primera intuición pero bueno eso fue
cuando hablé con ella sin embargo como
veremos aquí la intuición no es buena y
realmente para hacer esto hay que sacar
un pequeño truco y este truco vale la
pena un montón cada vez que vean algo
con raíces cuadradas y restando otra
cosa ya que lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar esencialmente por un por un
conjugado xxi sacan de números complejos
más o menos el conjugado de a más veces
a menos de dos o el conjugado de a menos
b es a más de verdad olvidan lo de los
números complejos es muy parecido a lo
que se hace ahí pero bueno
lo que vamos a hacer es entonces
multiplicar por a más b ya que nos
quedaría a cuadrada menos b cuadrada y
con él la cuadrada desaparecería la raíz
o que es demasiado trabajo lo que vamos
a hacer pero multiplicamos por el
conjugado de esta expresión y bueno
solo para no cambiar el valor tendremos
también que dividir entre ese número
verdad es decir multiplicó por raíz de x
cuadrada más 4 x + 1
ok y ahora + + x y dividido entre lo
mismo para no alterar el resultado es
decir estoy multiplicando por un número
1 y entonces dividido entre x cuadrada
más 4 x más 1 y luego más x déjenme
déjenme borrar estas cosas por aquí para
no distraernos muy bien no no queremos
distraernos así que que tenemos este va
a ser el límite el límite cuando x
tiende a infinito de quien ahora tenemos
esta expresión a menos b x además b
entonces va a ser esto al cuadrado que
es x cuadrada más 4 x más 1
- be cuadrada que en este caso bs x es
decir restamos x cuadrada y luego pues
nos queda dividir entre lo que tenemos
en el denominador que es raíz de x
cuadrada más 4 x + 1
y luego más x
y vamos a ver todavía hay una ligera
simplificación que podemos hacer aquí
tenemos x cuadrada menos equis cuadrada
por lo tanto los podemos cancelar
y ahora vamos a ver qué podemos hacer
bueno ya estamos tomando el límite
cuando x tiende al infinito y esto es lo
que normalmente hacemos cuando sacamos
un límite en el infinito dividimos
numerador y denominador por el
coeficiente perdón
la variable con el grado mayor verdad
entonces aquí lo que tendríamos es
dividir entre x tanto el numerador como
el denominador y recordemos que todo lo
que hagamos en el numerador hay que
hacerlo en el denominador para no
afectar el el resultado entonces
multiplicamos por uno entre x tanto
numerador como denominador y que nos
queda el límite cuando x tiende a
infinito de 4 que es 4 x entre x + 1
entre x sobre
ok aquí qué es lo que vamos a tener que
que es 1 / x de esa cosa bueno en
realidad esto parecería como un examen
de álgebra verdad porque queremos
calcular 1 entre x por la raíz cuadrada
de x cuadrada más 4 x más 1 lo voy a
hacer de este lado derecho pero bueno si
tomamos 1 entre x y lo queremos colocar
dentro de la raíz
tenemos que hacerlo con bueno elevándolo
al cuadrado verdad esto sería 1 sobre x
cuadrada 1 sobre x cuadrada que
multiplica podemos poner un 1 al
cuadrado pero es lo mismo pero que
multiplica x cuadrada más 4 x + 1 y debe
tener sentido ya para ustedes porque si
tomamos esta expresión esto se
simplifica muchísimo verdad entonces
quiere decir que vamos en la dirección
correcta
por supuesto suponiendo que estamos que
ustedes están cómodos con todas estas
operaciones de álgebra realmente es un
repaso de algunas propiedades de las
raíces y demás entonces esto se
convierte en la raíz cuadrada
de 1 / x que al meterlo es
1 / x cuadrada por x cuadrada es 1 y
luego 4 x / x pues nada más por si no
quedó muy claro vamos a hacerlo en
general 1 / x por la raíz cuadrada de a
simplemente es la raíz cuadrada de 1 al
cuadrado entre x cuadrada x a esto ya en
general no en este caso a es nuestro x
cuadrada más 4 x + 1
entonces 1 / x cuadrada por x cuadrado
es uno luego sumamos 4x / x cuadrada que
es 4 sobre x y luego más 1 sobre x al
cuadrado y luego 1 / x x x esto ya es
fuera de la raíz entonces esto se hace
de forma normal esto va a ser más 1
verdad que es x entre ellos ahora cuál
es el límite de esto cuando x tiende a
infinito este término de aquí se hace
cero también los términos que están
dentro de la raíz se hacen cero todo
esto se hace cero y lo que nos queda de
simplemente en el numerador
4 esto es 4 sobre sobre la raíz de 1
raíz de uno más uno y bueno eso solo es
4 sobre 2 que es simplemente 2
entonces no era 0 como pensamos al
inicio tuvimos que hacer muchos
problemitas de álgebra para llegar al
resultado vamos a hacer otro
en este ejercicio que vamos a hacer
tuvimos que sacudir nuestras cabezas
para sacar todas las las identidades
trigonométricas de las que nos
acordábamos pero bueno tomar el límite
realmente es algo sencillo son son solo
ejercicios de identidades
trigonométricas o de propiedades
algebraicas y demás entonces vamos a
hacer este este ejercicio el límite
cuando x se aproxima a cero de la cota
en gente con tangente de 2x sobre era
eso sí sí sí fue la cota agente de 2x
sobre la consecuente de x con secante de
x y este al igual que los problemas
anteriores más que un problema de
cálculo de pre cálculo en realidad es
para conocer identidades trigonométricas
así que quién es la constante de x bueno
esto es simplemente uno entre seno de x
con secante a lo mejor podría
confundirse con con la función inversa
perdón el recíproco de coseno pero no es
d
y ahora un lago tangente de 2 x 1 /
tangente de 2 x pero tangente seno /
coseno así que simplemente nos queda
coseno de 2x / seno de 2x verdad
entonces a qué es esto
esto a que es igual esto va a ser el
límite cuando x tiende a 0 de ccoo
tangente donde es de 2 x perdón que es
coseno de 2x entre entre seno de 2x y
ahora todo esto hay que dividirlo entre
la cosa cante pero con secante es uno
entre seno de xy bueno cuando dividimos
por el recíproco en realidad estamos
multiplicando esto es decir que el
límite cuando x tiende a cero de de que
hacemos bueno vamos a colocar el seno de
x
x dijimos que no como multiplicar verdad
seno de x por coseno de 2x sobre sobre
el seno de 2x no esto es simple
aritmética
y ahora todavía tenemos un problema
porque cuando evaluamos en 0 abajo se
vuelve 0 y se indeterminada también
arriba verdad así que esto no es
aceptable pero bueno quitemos esto para
nuestros que que no estorbe
y ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
simplificar todavía más verdad y aquí es
donde tenemos que es comprar nuestras
identidades trigonométricas porque no
hemos hecho una mayor manipulación de
hecho no tenemos que seno de x cuando x
es cero se hace cero lo mismo para seno
de 2x así que tenemos todavía que sacar
herramientas y la herramienta que
necesitamos es seno de 2x por qué seno
de 2x es dos veces el seno de x por el
cosenos verdad
así que después de haber pasado un largo
camino esto simplemente lo ponemos como
dos veces el seno de x por el seno de x
y ya está porque podemos simplificar ya
que tenemos seno de x tanto en el
numerador como en el denominador así que
estos se cancelan y que nos queda nos
quedamos con el límite cuando x tiende a
cero de coseno de 2x coseno de 2x entre
con dos veces el coseno de x y ahora
cuánto es coseno cuando vale cero es
decir cuando multiplican cuando
evaluamos en dos por cero verdad
entonces coseno de cero es uno sobre dos
por el coste no de cero que es 1 y esto
es simplemente un medio y ya está
creo que son los tres problemas
sustanciosos que tuve en la charla con
mi prima si lo resuelven estarán listos
para cualquier examen nos vemos en un
futuro vídeo